hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel where I am just about to stop
getting ready to host a 10th anniversary
party for Bioshock in an old train
station that's designed to look like a
rap show for tonight I am so excited to
take you guys this so I got to put
makeup on my face I got to go do a panel
and then the party of let's let's do it
step 1 step 2 step 4
[Music]
so this whole place is decked out with
water patents projected on the wall so
it actually looks like you're inside
rapture with fitting decorations and a
freakin string quartet playing ominous
rapture Eskom usek they're like splices
dancing everywhere which is a little bit
terrifying but mostly cool and a BA with
rapture themed cocktails I actually had
the plasmid it was super good but the
most exciting part for me is actually
the cosplay there are loads of
cosplayers here and we are just about to
start the cosplay competition which I'm
hosting and it's gonna be sort of like a
fashion show so I guess let's see who
brought their a-game are a lot of very
very creepy but very cool-looking little
sisters a guy who's like a humanoid
version of the song but coolest thing
about this guy was that his eyes would
change from red to cream which is just
like BioShock Infinite creepy very well
acted splices also in teams
Frank Fontaine a man himself and Jack
who came up behind him
very nice geoduck
a very handsome hook into it a unique
spin on the splicer little sister duo
this is actually a married couple
[Applause]
a bunch of elizabeth's including ones
that said catchphrases and threw coins
out into the audience as she does
[Music]
and an actual Big Daddy with a legit
drill super super suitable
[Applause]
so everyone is awesome but the guy who
actually won is dr. su Chong that I'm
creative plasmids with a drill through
his stomach what an awesome night
everyone looked so cool
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]